[Applause]
now back in washington the white house
is clarifying an off-the-cuff remark u.s
president joe biden made during a speech
in poland seeming to suggest it was time
for the russians to force president
vladimir putin out
for god's sake this man cannot remain
power the comment seemed to be a direct
call for regime change in russia white
house officials were quick to clear up
any confusion we do not have a strategy
of regime change in russia or anywhere
else for that matter it's up to the
people of the country in question it's
up to
the russian people the president did
extend an olive branch to the russian
people telling them they are not the
enemy the kremlin shot back saying it's
up to russian citizens to elect their
president but under putin's rule
elections have not been fair or free his
political opponents are often jailed or
silenced although some world leaders
believe this war could cost putin his
job the russian people i think are
pretty fed up
with what is happening
in ukraine this illegal invasion
the destruction of their own livelihoods
their economy
is collapsing around them before and
during the war the u.s has repeatedly
asked putin to come to the negotiating
table find a diplomatic way out
while france's president is calling for
this situation not to get out of control
others believe putin won't forget what
biden said it will play on his mind and
it could complicate matters going down
the road
still others say biden was just voicing
the hopes of millions around the world i
think many people will sympathize with
the sentiments
that led him to say what he did for now
the white house is sticking to its
statement that the u.s will not be
involved in any regime change in russia
instead the administration is moving
ahead with its strategy of cutting off
putin his billionaire backers and the
russian economy from the rest of the
world
jennifer johnson global news washington